et notre invité positive ce matin c'est
la députée écologiste de Paris bonjour
Sandrine merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de westfrance bonjour
Stéphane bonjour bonjour
et Sandrine Rousseau de la réforme des
retraites l'examen du texte a donc pris
fin à l'Assemblée nationale vendredi
minuit loin d'être allé jusqu'au bout
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge n'a
donc pas été examiné la France insoumise
a maintenu un très grand nombre
d'amendements jusqu'au bout de l'examen
est-ce que la France insoumise s'est
trompée de stratégie
c'est une stratégie que je n'ai pas
partagé et je pense que oui il faudra en
tirer le bilan après oui oui bien sûr
c'est que c'est à dire on tire le bilan
c'est à dire que en fait
je ne suis pas certaine qu'on puisse
mener un combat comme aussi important
que celui des retraites en étant sur une
stratégie qui soit isolée parce que le
que ce soit Philippe Martinez ou Laurent
Berger ou nous au sein de la nups nous
avions pour idée d'aller à cet article 7
d'en discuter puisque c'était le coeur
de la réforme et que probablement nous
le devions quand même aux citoyens
citoyen ce fameux article 7 pouvait être
rejeté par l'Assemblée puisque l'article
2 par exemple a été rejeté typiquement
c'était ça aurait donné une force
extraordinaire au mouvement ça si le si
à l'Assemblée l'article elle était
relative
le 7 aurait pu être gagné parce que
c'était évidemment mais parce que
c'était le coeur de la réforme et que
cristallise toutes les tous les toutes
les toutes les contrôles de c'était
c'était vraiment moi je l'ai appelé la
feuille de salade de cette c'est un mec
non mais vraiment c'était c'était une
pure décoration donc il y avait pas
d'enjeux quelque part à ne pas voter
l'article 2 ce qui était un peu
différent sur l'article 7 donc je pense
qu'il y avait quand même un risque que
l'article 7 passe mais quelque part
c'est un mouvement social avant tout ce
qui s'est passé ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est ce sont des grèves ce
sont des manifestations ce sont des gens
dans la rue ce sont des des personnes
qui perdent des journées de salaire et
tout cela est quand même orchestré
d'ailleurs bien orchestré par les
syndicats pour l'instant les
manifestations n'ont pas eu de
débordement elles sont nombreuses elles
sont pas vraiment tout se passe bien
dans la rue donc c'est pour cela que
pour moi il y avait vraiment une danse à
effectuer entre le entre la rue et
l'assemblée et que nous soyons en accord
les uns avec les autres
c'est pour ça que si les syndicats qui
organisent ces manifestations dans la
rue nous disait il fallait aller à
l'article 7 pour moi une femme et y
aller enfin je veux dire il y avait même
pas de question à se poser non pas que
ce soit les syndicat qui gouvernent
comme nous ont dit le gouvernement dans
l'assemblée mais simplement par respect
aussi de du travail qui défectue de
mobilisation des personnes ce qui n'est
jamais quelque chose de simple et là le
mouvement se passe bien et donc nous à
mon avis il y avait quelque chose à
vraiment Orchester
pour vous mais non pas de nuit mais en
tous les cas il y a ils ont voulu
s'imposer dans le dans le débat et je
pense que ça n'était pas le moment vous
leur en avez parlé pendant les débats
avant vendredi minuit il y a eu des
discussions
dans cette interview de la nuque comment
ça s'est passé tout à fait oui on a eu
des on avait des des réunions très
régulières parfois deux trois par jour
donc vraiment on se parlait beaucoup et
oui ils savent que nous étions pas sur
la même ligne et ils ont décidé de faire
cela très bien c'est leur stratégie je
la respecte aussi mais je dis juste là
je pense que ça veut dire que
majoritairement la fin de l'interview de
la nuque c'était votre ligne qui était
majoritaire
mais je sais pas si on est socialiste
pour vous
en tous les cas il y a eu une volonté de
s'imposer voilà mais il va falloir
est-ce qu'il va falloir retravailler je
pense qu'il va que ça signe un peu la
fin d'un acte 1 de la news qui a
fonctionné jusqu'à présent qui était
issu de l'élection présidentielle et que
maintenant nous passons nous devons
passer à un acte 2 lequel acte 2 doit
être fait essentiellement enfin d'abord
à mon avis au sein de l'assemblée et
puis après on verra ce que les parties
souhaitent faire mais en tous les cas au
sein de l'assemblée je pense qu'il va
falloir revoir en effet comment manière
dont nous fonctionnons
en faisant en sorte qu'il y ait une
coordination qui prenne des décisions
avec des quelque chose qui soit beaucoup
plus finalement claire et démocratique
j'ai envie de dire si
au sein de la nuque c'est pas une
question d'hégémonie c'est une question
de vouloir
continuer sur la ligne de LFI elle est
finie enfin je pense qu'il y a une
différence entre LFI et la nuance ça
c'est un vœu que vous formulez
aujourd'hui où il y a déjà des
discussions qui ont commencé autour de
cet acte 2 devrait devenir pour
l'instant on est pour l'instant moi je
respecte aussi le débat sur les
retraites c'est-à-dire que là il faut
que aller au Sénat il faut qu'il y ait
la CMP il faut qu'on ça revienne en
hémicycle il faut que nous soyons dans
la rue et en fait il y a toute cette
séquence à terminer et vraiment moi je
ne sais pas après après la fin de quand
vous avez vu par exemple ce tweet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui clairement tapé
sur les communistes c'est-à-dire sur ses
alliés au sein de l'année oui j'en étais
pas contente et je pense que c'est une
erreur voilà donc il y a un problème
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a eu un
problème avec cette tweet sur justement
on va en parler et des conséquences
musculaires il y a eu un sondage du
Journal du Dimanche sur le meilleur
opposant à cette réforme et c'est le
rassemblement national qui arrive devant
la nuque dans ce sondage est-ce que avec
cette stratégie Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
fait le jeu tu rassemblements national
je me permettrais pas de dire ça du tout
par contre il y a quand même quelque
chose qui me fascine absolument c'est
que et je vais le dire avec
les mots qui sont les miens mais
vraiment le rassemblement a été nul dans
cette séquence dans cette séquence mais
là nul c'est-à-dire que ce soit en
commission des affaires sociales ou en
hémicycle c'était dramatique les les
députés du rassemblement national en
commission à faire sociale ont été
inexistants mais il n'existant en
émissaire une fois pour Macron une fois
pour il s'abstenait une fois de temps en
temps un peu avec nous mais le plus
souvent avec Macron et le plus souvent
ils étaient la réforme de Macron et
qu'il s'en sortent et me fascine s'il y
a qu'en fait mais ça c'est tous les
mouvements d'extrême droite et on l'a vu
au Brésil on l'a vu aux États-Unis c'est
que en fait ils
d'une main il est il tombe une espèce de
de leur pour que tout le monde
s'accroche à ça et là en l'occurrence
c'était la natalité l'immigration etc
mais de l'autre en fait ils aident des
intérêts économiques partout et les plus
grands intérêts économiques bolsonaro a
façon son mandat a été celui où les
grandes entreprises qui détruisaient les
forêts et qui bénéficiaient et qui
faisaient du profit sur les biens
communs ce sont le plus enrichis pareil
pour Trump et en fait c'est exactement
ce qui se passe avec le rassemblement
national en France dire que ce qu'ils
font c'est qu'ils aident les intérêts
économiques puis ils tendent une main
comme ça en disant regardez regardez
l'immigration mais en fait au fond ce
sont les plus grands alliés des intérêts
économiques et donc oui ça c'est vu lors
de la réforme des retraites je suis une
navrée par contre que les personnes ne
le perçoivent pas et je me demande et
c'est une vraie question que je me pose
comment peut-on mettre en lumière ça
parce que c'est tellement flagrant c'est
tellement flagrant dans l'hémicycle que
je suis surprise du fait que ça ne
compte pas le problème c'est que dans
l'hémicycle qu'est-ce que les gens
regardent qu'est-ce qu'on regarde tous
collectivement c'est le barouf c'est les
gens qui crient c'est l'agitation et ça
détourne toute l'attention là vous êtes
en train d'expliquer les choses mais le
spectacle qui est donné à l'Assemblée
vous avez quand même bien conscience que
ce que ce que tout le monde regarde
c'est le bordel entre parenthèses pour
reprendre l'expression
c'est quelque chose aussi qui est très
instrumentalisé la question du bordel
comme je vous le dites parce que
la stratégie on en a parlé j'ai des
désaccords autant sur le enfin une
opposition ça
c'est normal et ça le dit et l'hémicycle
n'est pas un salon monté hein dans
lequel nous discute rien de manière
comme ça
avec constructive votre proposition
est-ce que c'est la question en tous les
cas ça a donné cette réforme mais de
toute façon nous n'avons pas la majorité
dans les missing donc je veux dire c'est
au cœur du sujet et d'ailleurs c'est au
cœur du sujet de la Cinquième République
c'est à dire que on a un problème avec
la Cinquième République moi ce que j'ai
expérimenté et ce qui m'a vraiment
frappé dans cette réforme des retraites
c'est que nous députés de l'opposition
nous avons les les décorum du pouvoir ça
nous avons des Corum du pouvoir mais
nous n'en avons aucun en réalité dans
l'hémicycle à part de de rendre public
des choses en fait et de dire haut et
fort des choses c'est ce nous avons fait
ça pour me dire le rassemblement
national eux ils disent si la nuque
avait voté avec nous la motion de
censure si la nuque avec nous la motion
ça aurait pu faire changer les choses
c'est absolument pas elle ne passait
absolument
d'Emmanuel Macron parce que vous avez
empêché de bloquer cette réforme mais
elle ne passait absolument pas il faut
une majorité mais le RN ne sait très
bien il faut 50 % donc eux puissent nous
ça ne fait pas le 50% pareil en moi à
titre personnel et je le redis je l'ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois je ne voterai
jamais jamais une loi venant du
rassemblement national jamais voilà hier
soir disait que c'est du secteur ils
peuvent ils peuvent penser que c'est du
sectarisme pour moi je ne il y a une
ligne rouge qui est que je ne collabore
pas avec l'extrême droite jamais jamais
et ça n'est pas discutable et je
comprends que dans la dans la rue les
gens puissent avoir des des doutes en se
disant on a tellement banalisé le
rassemblement national on l'a tellement
simplifié et dit que finalement c'était
un parti comme les autres que bien sûr
que les gens ne comprennent plus mais
[Musique]
ces gens n'ont pas de valeur ces gens
n'ont pas de valeur ils n'ont que le
fric le fric le fric la croissance la
croissance ils n'ont que ça comme ligne
de conduite ils n'ont pas de valeur
profondément ils n'ont pas d'ancrage
dans les territoires ils n'ont pas
d'ancrage dans les petites villes et les
et les campagnes les ruralités n'ont
aucune ville et en fait ils n'ont qu'une
seule chose à la tête c'est le fric le
fric moi je ne veux plus enfin vraiment
c'est c'est d'une arrogance qui défile
entendement que vous n'avez qu'une seule
chose ce sont les taxes et les impôts
je rappelle quand même que les impôts
c'est la justice sociale pardon mais ça
aussi c'est fascinant c'est à dire que
d'ailleurs ça confirme exactement ce que
je vous dis c'est à dire que les impôts
c'est la justice sociale il n'y a pas de
justice il n'y a pas d'égalité dans un
pays sans impôts et là ce que l'on fait
depuis des années maintenant c'est de
réduire les impôts des plus riches et
d'augmenter ce des plus pauvres donc en
fait ce que l'on fait c'est qu'on fait
peser la réforme fiscale sur les plus
pauvres et là il y a eu des baisses
impôts pour les classes moyennes il y a
eu des baisses d'impôts pour les
Français les plus modestes ben là c'est
un impôt sur la vie de deux ans hein
c'est ça qui se passe pour payer les
entreprises en fait donc là c'est à fond
renversé complet et on n'a jamais autant
baissé les impôts sur les entreprises et
sur les plus riches que sous Emmanuel
Macron donc en fait ce que quand ils
disent pas d'impôt pas d'impôts faut
entendre pas d'impôts sur les plus
riches oui bah d'accord bah donc on est
exactement dans ce que je vous dis c'est
le fric le fric le fric quoi sur le
mouvement social donc vous appelez un
blocage les 7 mars on a compris est-ce
que vous appelez aussi à une action le 8
mars jour de la journée du droit des
femmes des droits des femmes pardon
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire ce
jour-là mais je vais aller manifester il
y a une très grande manifestation qui
est prévue et je serai parmi les
personnes qui marcheront dans ce cortège
et j'appelle vraiment les hommes à venir
soutenir ce mouvement de libération et
d'émanciper vous préférez parce que oui
bien sûr j'en ferai et puis voilà je ne
vais pas vous les dire à l'avance pour
lui exactement mais surtout ce que
vraiment il y a quelque chose que je sur
lequel je voudrais alerter c'est que ce
qui est apparu dans le mot dans le débat
sur les retraites et qui est je trouve
dans le dans le discours du
rassemblement national c'est la question
de la natalité et pardon mais la
natalité qui est une natalité en fait de
femmes blanches
puisqu'ils ne veulent pas du de ce
qu'ils appellent et qui est un fantasme
le grand remplacement et ça c'est
vraiment un marqueur d'extrême droite
que de renvoyer les femmes à un corps à
une natalité à une fonction de
procréation il n'est pas question et je
le dis avec la natalité
qu'il a été beaucoup question de la
natalité de femmes blanches ça a quand
même suscité quelques critiques c'est
quoi une natalité de femmes blanches en
fait sur le rassemblement national a
estimé que le problème de la retraite
c'était la natalité ce qui est faux
puisque de toute façon avant qu'un
enfant qui naît aujourd'hui travail il y
a 20 ans minimum donc de toute façon ça
n'est pas le sujet ça n'est pas vrai par
contre il voulait profiter de cette
réforme des retraites pour faire des
politiques natalistes pour relancer la
natalité en France parce qu'ils
estimaient qu'on avait un problème de
natalité et ça c'est profondément
renvoyé des femmes à une fonction
uniquement de procréation moi je dis nos
ventre ne sont pas la variable
d'ajustement des de la réforme des
retraites et c'est et encore une fois
c'est une fatalité de femmes blanches
c'est ça qu'on croyait pas que des
femmes il y avait l'histoire parce que
par exemple s'il y a un problème de
population qu'on ouvre un peu les les
personnes immigrées qu'on efface rentrer
au nom de quoi au nom de quoi des
personnes qui viendraient travailler en
sèche les personnes de nationalité
française il y a pas que des femmes
blanches ah ben oui mais quand on les
entend quand on les entend je pense que
parce que la théorie qui était
sous-jacente c'était la théorie du Grand
remplacement et cette théorie du Grand
remplacement c'est que ce sont c'est la
population blanche et chrétienne qui est
qui est menacée par d'autres populations
et notamment la natalité de ces autres
populations et précisément ça c'est
fasciste enfin je le dis il y a c'est
raciste et c'est fasciste donc il y a
pas de il y a pas de à aller vers cela
d'aucune manière après on comme un
problème sur notre système de
répartition et pas comme la retraite
c'est aussi la sécurité sociale le
chômage etc ça tombe de d'assurance
sociale qui sont financés par les actifs
qui travaillent et derrière il y a la
problématique de la démographie
vous venez parler de la natalité mais on
a quand même un problème de démographie
dans ce pays non non vous dites la
solution c'est d'ouvrir et c'est
d'ouvrir et de de compenser en faisant
venir des travailleurs immigrés comme le
fait l'Allemagne ou d'autres d'autres
pays européens la terre a suffisamment
d'humain sur cette pleine enfin il y a
suffisamment d'humain sur cette planète
on a donc un problème objectivement de
corrélation entre les ressources et le
nombre d'humains on organise on organise
les déplacements pour compenser
préserver notre vie notre modèle social
il y a aucun problème de population il y
a juste un problème de fermeture des
frontières et un problème mais quand je
dis ça je ne voudrais pas non plus
laisser entendre que l'immigration se
résoudrait à une question économique
c'est-à-dire c'est une question avant
tout humaine avant tout de droits
humains et mais et d'ailleurs là on va
voir la loi immigration qui va arriver
dans les liens entre les deux
probablement va ouvrir la possibilité de
d'avoir des titres de séjour plus
facilement dans des métiers dit en
tension et notamment dans les soins des
personnes probablement dans les métiers
du soin qui manquent cruellement de de
salariés donc je pense que on va le voir
la semaine prochaine je pense pas que ce
soit une solution je pense juste que en
fait il suffit de faire ça pour qu'il
n'y ait aucune espèce de discours sur la
natalité sauf que c'est précisément ce
que le rassemblement national ne veut
pas faire une dernière question
là-dessus après on va passer au reste de
l'actualité le texte va revenir
l'Assemblée nationale après son examen
Sénat est-ce que vous souhaitez une
autre stratégie pour la nuque
lors du retour de l'examen de ce texte
au retour dans l'hémicycle mais de toute
façon là il va y avoir une commission
mixte paritaire la CMP bon c'est de la
technique parlementaire mais en fait à
la fin il n'y aura juste un vote
solennel en hémicycle avec une prise de
parole par groupe donc ça ne changera
rien enfin là il y a plus de questions
de stratégie maintenant cette question
l'année dernière
puisque marine tondeuse secrétaire
nationale d'Europe Écologie les verse se
donne 150 jours pour poser les bases
d'un nouveau mouvement écologiste avec
un objectif ambitieux un million de
sympathisants en 2027 je rappelle que
vous avez 11000 adhérents aujourd'hui
c'est réaliste
je pense qu'on en a même déjà pas mal en
fait je sais pas je saurais pas les
chiffrer mais je pense qu'on en a déjà
pas mal et il se voit à chaque élection
donc oui c'est non seulement c'est
réaliste mais c'est il faut qu'on y
arrive c'est ce qu'il faut mettre fin à
Europe Écologie Les Verts tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui mais fin Europe
Écologie Les Verts
elle a dit qu'elle était pas contre
penser les bases rechanger de nom
refaire c'est une question qui est posée
à tous les partis politiques je pense
que la forme partie d'air aujourd'hui
est une forme qui qui est très contestée
par les citoyens et citoyennes pas ils
ne se reconnaissent pas dans cette forme
là donc oui revoir de fond en comble
après moi j'ai toujours cette phrase en
tête qui est on peut tout changer pour
ne rien changer mais l'idée c'est de
revoir à quoi sert un parti politique
aujourd'hui en France et en quoi il peut
servir des mouvements sociaux et je
pense que ça on a une discussion à avoir
la vie
je pense de la refondation mais quelle
sera précisément votre rôle personnel
dans cette fondation vous y prenez pas
ou pas ou pas du tout je prendrai tout
ma part
je ne sais pas encore puisque je ne sais
pas encore quelle contour précis ça va
prendre cette refondation mais j'y
prendrai ma part changer de nom pour
devenir les écologistes c'est une piste
ça c'est bien quand même
contributions
à l'Assemblée ça peut être déjà les
écologistes c'est pas un peu dommage de
perdre le marqueur Europe dans Europe
Écologie Les Verts il y a Europe c'est
votre force en fait on parle pas
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts la plupart
du temps on parle de EELV et je pense
que vraiment c'est le le
nom le moins enthousiasmant qui puisse
exister Yannick Jadot et candidat pour
être sénateur de Paris ce serait un bon
candidat pour vous
mais tout les candidats seront bons pour
les sénateurs et je pense que les
la phase des candidatures n'est pas
terminée donc
candidat en fait que ce soit lui j'étais
lui de Paris vous aussi je verrai déjà
tous les candidats qu'il y aura et on
verra donc de toute façon ce sera à ce
sera un pense sénateur si les sénateurs
à la fin bien entendu on va parler de
une autre une autre actualité dont on
parle on parle plus du tout très peu en
tout cas on n'entend plus parler c'est
la convention citoyenne pour la fin de
vie ce que vous suivez les travaux ou
est-ce qu'on en est
c'est ce sont des travaux qui
la convention citoyenne et il y a le
groupe parlementaire la convention
citoyenne a donné un premier avis hier
qui n'est pas encore formalisé mais qui
montre que 70% de des membres de cette
commission souhaitent de cette
convention pardon souhaite une évolution
de la loi moi je souhaite de mais je
souhaite de toutes mes forces une
évolution de la loi je pense plus de 80%
à sauter une évolution de la loi 75% à
vouloir une aide active à mourir et je
et moi de toutes mes forces je
soutiendrai une aide active à mourir et
une évolution de la loi pourquoi parce
que je pense que aujourd'hui
notre fin de vie
peut-être de 12 et comme nous le
souhaitons mais elle peut aussi pour
certains et certaines nous être volés et
ça n'est pas possible en fait c'est le
dernier axe c'est un acte très important
en fait que de mettre un point final
dans une aventure aussi incroyable qui
est la vie et celles et ceux qui
souhaitent en avoir la maîtrise doivent
pouvoir l'avoir donc vous demandez
Elisabeth World qui aura qui recevra ses
conclusions mi-mars c'était pas les
conclusions définitives c'était un vote
mais vous demandez à Elisabeth borde de
suivre ça et de lancer un processus
législatif pour qu'il y ait une aide
active à mourir oui et je ne sens pas
aujourd'hui le gouvernement extrêmement
proactif là-dedans je les pense trop
prudent et je pense que c'est un débat
qui est très majoritairement tranché
dans la société et beaucoup de nos
citoyens veulent une aide active à
mourir veuve au moins la possibilité
d'une aide active à mourir en plus il
faut ce qu'il faut bien comprendre dans
cette activamourir c'est que on y
recourt pas forcément mais ne faites
même de savoir qu'on n'y a recours peut
apaiser la fin de vie donc en fait c'est
vraiment du bon sens vous craignez que
le gouvernement ne suivent pas le
je n'ai pas senti de volonté farouche du
gouvernement d'aller vers ça donc elle
va être enterrée pour vous il y a un
risque mais je pense aussi qu'il y a que
nous sommes plusieurs parlementaires à
l'intérieur d'un hémicycle à ne pas
vouloir que ce soit intérêt justement ça
pourrait ça pourrait faire l'objet d'une
proposition de loi transpartisane oui
vous avez vous avez commencé à y
réfléchir vous avez travaillé ou pas
alors concrètement non mais je fais
partie de du groupe d'évaluation de la
loi classe néonetti et je pense qu'à
l'issue de cela quand les conclusions
seraient rendues nous verrons qu'il y a
besoin d'une évolution de la loi
dernière question sur ce qu'a dit hier
Gérald Darmanin suite à l'accident de
Pierre Palmade Stéphane oui Gérard
Darmanin suite à cet accident propose un
retrait du permis moins 12 points d'un
coup si en cas de conduite sous
stupéfiant qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez est-ce qu'on en revient à
fait divers une proposition de loi ou
est-ce que c'est ou c'est justifié de
votre
un fait divers une proposition de loi ça
n'a aucun sens c'est du c'est de la coup
c'est du sensationnel et ça n'a pas de
donc il faut passer même en fait pour la
démocratie véritablement surtout que sur
la question des addictions il y a bien
mieux à faire que d'être dans la
répression comme ça bête et méchant j'ai
envie de dire la consommation de drogue
de stupéfiants est avant tout un
problème de santé publique avant tout
avant tout et donc où sont les
politiques de santé publique où
sont-elles ou sont les politiques qui
permettent de diminuer et d'accompagner
les personnes qui sont dépendantes il y
en a quasiment pas quasiment pas la
prévention il faut pas durcir la loi non
mais en tout cas
il y a quand même un truc qui est que
dans la politique de lutte contre les
drogues on est soit dans la drogue c'est
mal voilà soit dans on tape on tape les
consommateurs enfin il y a quand même un
tout petit peu plus intelligent à faire
et là en l'occurrence j'appelle Gérald
Darmanin à faire preuve d'un tout petit
peu et quand à sanctionné davantage les
comportements sous emprise de drogue qui
mettent en danger d'autres vies sur la
route oui mais pas comme ça pas sur un
coup de tête et avec une politique de
prévention et avec une politique qui l'a
augmenté les contrôles de piano qui
travaillent sur la question de
l'homicide depuis décembre avec du pont
n'a qu'une seule chose c'est taper sur
les consommateurs en fait c'est ça sa
seule politique de répression des
drogues mais c'est vraiment la pire des
manières de faire en fait merci Sandrine
Rousseau merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité on regarde la ligne de
Ouest-France les accueille d'urgence si
essentiel aux enfants c'est à la Une de
votre journal Stéphane Stéphane on se
retrouve demain oui avec plaisir bonne
journée merci Sandrine Rousseau on passe
au club des territoires